history TV
up next on American history TV author
David Reed talks about his book the
brazen age New York City and the
American Empire politics art and whoa he
Mia in a conversation with New York
University history professor Thomas
bender mr. Reed argues that between 1945
and 1950 World War two New York City
became a haven for exiles and a world
center for literature art music and
economic creativity the museum of the
city of New York hosted this hour-long
event and it is now my great pleasure to
introduce our speakers
they have fuller BIOS in our program
which should have been on your seat
Thomas bender is an intellectual and
cultural historian whose many books
include New York intellect the
unfinished city and a nation among
nations America's place in world history
he is professor of history and
university of professor of humanities at
New York University David Reed is editor
of sex death and God in LA and co-editor
of West of the West imagining California
his essays articles reviews and
interviews have appeared in Vanity Fair
The Paris Review the New York Times The
Washington Post the longa long hello
excuse me Los Angeles Times Book Review
and in various anthologies including
pushcart price
won't you please join me in welcoming
David Reed who will speak a little bit
about his book and then be joined by
Professor bender
[Applause]
Thank You Lily uh it's a pleasure and an
honor to be here in connection with this
distinguished series this is also a
memorable occasion for me because it is
my first PowerPoint presentation so I'll
bear with me and I may be the only
person in America with a BA who knows da
who does not have any experience in this
medium but I'm going to start cooking
and got the microphone adjusted okay a
little bit over here great okay
this is just a very a very brief survey
of New York pictorially in this period
we begin with this vent with this
fantastic shot of the financial district
in the mid 30s from Berenice Abbott's
fabulous pww a series WPA series
changing New York and here you have the
classic Vista in a topless towers the
ala bastard walls the fortress of money
the ships the lonely ship going out to
see the steam rising above the landscape
but below this there was at the
beginning of the 30s a stricken
landscape the landscape of the early
depression which it was said it was
worse to be down and out in New York
that in London or Paris or any other
great world city one thing it seemed to
be becoming was a kleptocracy it seemed
as if the mobs had seized the effective
control of New York and this feeling
became more and more intense as it in
that interval a terrifying and yet
strangely becalmed one between the
realization that Herbert Hoover was
effectively helpless in the face of the
depression and the coming of the New
Deal in in numerous novels you find
people such as John O'Hara's Butterfield
a you find people saying what will
governor Roosevelt do when he becomes
president the answer was no one was
really quite certain in the meanwhile
the mobs ruled the street and here we
have a shot by ouija perhaps the most
famous photographer of New York and one
of his specialties the demise of an
eminent gangster usually these shots
would include a
Dora which was sort of a signature of a
late gangster appearing in the tabs it
was sometimes suspected that Ouija
actually planted the Fedora
in this one he's wearing in this case
he's wearing one and the gangster is out
of sight in in the car behind the wheel
now here we skip the whole New Deal era
we go we go straight from the stricken
city of 1933 to the victorious city of
1945 as you see the troops returning to
New York and marching through Washington
Square you had a city which in night
which twelve years before seemed as if
it were paralyzed the city at which of
which the German poet Brecht wrote that
once its boxers were the swiftest its
bankers the richest and now it was the
pitiable giant of a city now New York
stood at the summit of the world it was
Daniel Patrick Moynihan said the most
successful place in the history of
mankind but what did it actually look
like at street level it had changed
surprisingly little because during the
Great Depression the gigantic cyclopean
building projects of the 1920s the
Empire State Building the Chrysler
Building and they're like if they had
their life had been effectively stalled
there were the bridges and built by the
New Deal order for which the so called
master builder Robert Moses is often
given credit as if he were an
independent force of nature and perhaps
he was to a certain extent but would
certainly have never been built without
the patronage of FDR who loathed him and
LaGuardia who had an uneasy partnership
well here you see to celebrate the faces
of a multicultural City the Italians a
little italy on v-j day living among
scenes that were effectively unchanged
for the last half-century
but would soon be remarkably altered and
transformed by the suburban age that was
approaching now here might seem
something entirely different but these
are exactly the soldiers whom you would
have seen returning to what was in 1945
still an urban nation at that time the
electoral weight of the country was
effectively
it's just 16 densely settled urban
counties these count these counties
including flourish New York's
constituted the nation of won the war
there was a time roughly I perhaps it
could be calculated now by computer in
nineteen for the winter of nineteen
forty seven forty eight when the United
States went from the having its largest
proportion apps in absolute terms at is
a percentage of the population its
largest urban population defined as
people living in cities spewed party of
a hundred thousand or over and the
process of suburbanization that began at
that time so here are the boys in the
army as they were still known and what
were they doing they were reading books
the avidity for print was so
extraordinary during the war and
especially on the battle fronts that
calm you know the comrades would
actually tear out the signatures of a
paperback book as they finished them and
hand them to a buddy books of hope looks
of poetry sold books of books of what
amounted to very softcore porn sold like
you are my beloved with its vegetable
analogies uh but also Henry James and F
scott Fitzgerald became bestsellers at
this time and publishers wondered could
it blast after the war was over would
the boys and their wives keep reading
books and an odd thing happened they did
what they stopped doing was going to the
movies they had retired to private
pursuits like reading and procreating
and in this and in this and in this
matter was born the suburban nation that
was to succeed the New Deal nation now
here again we're talking about a city of
print and here's the the newsroom of the
New York Times now let's not forget the
New York Times had a rival The Herald
Tribune which was the newspaper of the
establishment the newspaper of the wasps
the newspaper of the established rather
than the striving and the newspaper
which also published excellent prose it
was a saying among journalists in those
days that the weakness of the New York
was sex I know this sounds like science
fiction but that was what was said and
the weakness of the Herald Tribune was
alcohol alcohol led to better prose now
at this time when you have New York is a
city of images as that Empire of signs
no pres Lord was more powerful that
Henry Luce here shown with some with
some carefully attempted newsmen hanging
on his every word at the end of the
Second World War
time life was simply the most powerful
media empire ever its magazines girdled
the earth it was an Oracle of
intellectual authority and certainly
attempted to do the same in them in the
Department of politics it was ubiquitous
Life magazine actually more people or
advertisers spent more money on Life
magazine alone than on any television or
radio network those were the days to be
involve of print but the future relay
elsewhere as we know and here we have
Edward our borough Eric severide
representing the Empire of the air after
the after the war radio and television
it ceased to just be a headline service
and the consequences are those that we
all know on the other hand you had the
small magazine represented by partisan
review which exercised an intellectual
ascendancy quite out of you know
correspondence with it's very modest
circulation never more than 10,000 or so
in this picture we see representing the
in a certain part of the intellectual
elite and the expatriate writers who
came in found Broadwater who is best
known to history as being married to
Mary McCarthy Nichol CaroMont a an
exiled writer from Italy Elizabeth
Hardwick who was subsequently married to
Robert Lowell extraordinary essayist and
editor of the New York Review of Books
Miriam Kyra mente in the center looking
slightly a Trotsky s is Dwight MacDonald
perhaps the most in gifted intellectual
gadfly of all time in America Mary
McCarthy is right you know he's seated
next to John Barrowman the poet - the
beard of later years and in front is her
brother Kevin
McCarthy V actor here we have one type
of the post-war writer as culture hero
basically the writer who wore plaid
shirts and who represented the principle
of Jewish moral earnestness Arthur
Miller and his anti-type Truman Capote
represent representing the author as S
feet and we know that both of these acts
were going to have a pretty long run
here we have a different kind of culture
hero Leonard Bernstein whose debut was
legendary and who attracted the same
kind of frenzied adulation from teenage
fans as did Frank Sinatra here we have
the art world represented in the first
of the exiled art world representative
the person of Salvador Dali who looking
rather clean-cut in his shop striped
suit and to the end of the left his
dealer Julian levy and here we have the
floor you know here we have a ballet
troupe the American city troupe of in
1942 I believe the four temperaments
here we have about George Balanchine
representing the European art world in
his own person again and Laurens heart
of heart of Hammerstein and heart and
here we have a kind of gathering of
darlings of the Gods at the cafe
Nicholson on East 54th Street 1950
Tanika Leclerc who was married to
Balanchine and who tragically was to
develop polio within a few years though
she continued her career no longer able
to dance she continued her career as a
teacher if Donald Wyndham a riot of
writer
Buffy Campbell I think you probably
recognize Tennessee Williams and Garvey
Dahl and here we have a group known as
the irascible zazz they work as they
were characterized by the Herald Tribune
the abstract expressionist painters who
were protesting the juried selections at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art and among
the usual probably recognizable and de
Kooning broth Co and Jackson Pollock
looking at that curious guarded hooded
expression the post-war masculinity
liked to affect at the time
here we have their dealer Betty Parsons
who sort of gave us the white wall bare
floor gallery and who said they'd give
me paintings I give them walls here we
in here I this was this the selection
was inspired by a letter by Harry Truman
to his wife Margaret Truman in which he
said the day after he declared the
Truman Doctrine sort of inaugurating the
Cold War
that it was he was opposed only by
crackpots like Henry Wallace his
predecessor as president vice president
shown here among schoolchildren during
his 1948 presidential run and Woody
Guthrie who supported it and here
exactly are the kind of immoral artists
and writers of Greenwich Village as
Harry Truman called them represented
represented here by Montgomery Clift
Jack Kerouac and a frustratingly
unidentified man with a quizzical
expression and here are the avatars of
the Beat Generation to come of course
Jack Kerouac and Neal Cassady and it may
interest you to know that Jack Cassidy
of them were present for Harry Truman's
inauguration as president in 1949 and
here we return to a you know a classic
vision by a god show of New York as Oz
the sort of risen city of the post-war
anyway this is my mini tour of this
decade and I hope to learn more about it
from you tonight thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much for that visual run
through those that was really quite
wonderful I want to begin by just saying
if I were asked by a publisher to
describe this book what I would have
said but I'm going to say I would say
that this is a big book and if it were
imprinted with the all-caps
it is a wonderful and richly populated
really populated with a wide range of
New Yorkers precisely captured in fine
prose summit length many at various
lengths some beautifully captured in a
single phrase it lays out a vast
panorama of the arts politics and the
lives of particularly the many writers
and artists I think it shows a couple of
skills too long with many others but I
want to make a point about these and
they're not always found in the same
author first an incredible range the
energy that radiates through the book of
the many people and works he talks about
so many writers as you just saw he can
capture in a few words a picture a text
so many writers that I wanted to go to
the index and literally count them how
many did this man have his capacity to
elucidate well unfortunately I had the
page proofs that didn't have anything
else so I don't know but I think it's
when you pick up a book back there you
might want to want to do that the other
thing is a second virtue a David reader
so is a writer we academics think we are
writers that we actually mostly are not
and I think that this makes this
eminently readable but my my first real
question to me is an obvious one and he
probably won't be surprised here's a man
who lives in California who's done two
books on California writes a lot about
California in other media why go to New
York well as I would have to say that it
that well thank you for that extremely
handsome and generous comment but I
would have to say apart that it was
writers like yourself who sent me on
this path I was like I can remember not
to spare Tom's blushes but I can
remember the day I can even name it was
May 3rd I think 1983 that I came across
his book New York intellect at the hbj
bookstore Harcourt brace jovanovich for
those of you who go back that far which
had been moved to the headquarters to
the despair of the editors had been
moved to San Diego by Williams
ivanovitch who had fond memories of
being there as a soldier during the war
you could imagine the desolation you
know going from midtown Manhattan to San
Diego but it was charms
RGV those of geography but it but the
idea the history of York oh yeah an
American writer of anything I don't
think it can escape grappling with New
York one way or another as a publishing
Center as a cynosure there's a rather
terrifying line of of John Gunther's
that I like to quote in which compass
says that there is no in the field of
culture at least and even by implication
in everything else there is no
definitive success in American life
unless it is ratified by New York
opinion you see added I do not say this
is a good thing I just say it is the
case and there was that and then and
then the the you know not to go on to LA
but the short answer is that many years
ago my agent sandy Dykstra asked if I'm
I signed with her asked if I had a book
I wanted to write and I said and and did
I have a proposal and I said I didn't
have a proposal but I did have a book
and she said all right just write a
letter no more than two page
address it to be but mate write it so
that it can be read without there's my
other eyes and I can she said so what's
what I said way to be about I said well
I always thought it'd be interesting to
write about the period directly after
World War two for one thing that's what
my generation came in for another there
was a great period of cultural glories
there was bebop there was a film noir
there was a Renaissance of American
Novel and play the beginnings of really
television and so on and of course most
of that was going on in New York New
York was the undisputed cultural capital
and so that's how I got started she sold
the book and then I was lashed to the
mast well okay I want to say and pose
another question about the book the
title the brazen age I thought I knew
what brazen men but I thought it was an
odd choice and so I went to the
dictionary my American Heritage
Dictionary and listen to this the first
part of the definition said marked by
flagrant and insolent audacity and then
it had I can asterisk that you go to a
special little box at the bottom of the
page synonyms shameless and then it goes
on to say these adjectives there are a
couple other bracketed with brazen these
adjectives apply to people and personal
hate behavior that are in defiance of
social and moral proprieties and are
marked by a bold lack of shame so I
think you just gave a different vision I
do think that there that there was the
audacity was was was a virtue what was
sorry I started virtue it's a strange
thing I discovered when I began going
online to see if this book was getting
any publicity that in fact it didn't get
you for a long time it really was like
the third or fourth or seventh or
whatever
a title that came up because it turned
out that there was the first title that
came up was my life in the brazen age
which was a book written by somebody in
London in the 8th of the late 1600s
surely there's nothing new under it
under them to the side so one learns all
kinds of things about York one's book
and I myself online if you go to a
certain website from independent
bookstores you could also find out that
I wrote this book and the hiatus from my
training is a Navy SEAL a cup I don't
know why that's so funny but know what
the title actually derives from from
from a line by gore Vidal and that my
agent pointed out to me when I wrote
this note to her I quoted a line which
is the opening of the introduction in
which gore Vidal is writing in 1974
during the dark days of Richard Nixon's
presidency and he says from December 7th
1941 until August 14 1974 presumably the
date he was writing the United States
has been more or less continuously at
war with the exception of a brief too
little celebrated interval 1945 1950 in
which we enjoyed for Americans if not a
golden at least not to raisin and hay
and Sandy phone and said you realize
he's had to do your title so I went with
but the funny thing is I did I
subsequently realized or was alerted by
an erudite friend that if you look at
the poet hesiod you find now you say
when you got me started I look at the
poet hesiod he talks about the golden
age being being transformed into bronze
by violence and here you have a golden
age that ends up with another war ok
there's as I've already said there's so
many characters we've gotten some sense
of the range of the
by doing something wrong here closer we
got some sense of what was on the screen
of the the range of things I guess I
would like to have you say something
about the most difficult group or
individual you had to deal with in terms
of getting it right so to speak maybe
even the one that you ended up feeling
more and more uncomfortable with and
then the other side of that the one that
you either just it was a cinch you just
instantly add this person figured out or
however you came to understand someone
but someone who you understood in a very
positive significant way now that's that
is a fascinating question because I did
in the course of writing this book
continually find finding finding myself
and at this at this point might might my
editor my sigh reminiscent sigh sort of
falling in love in a bizarre and
perverse way with some of my characters
some of whose direct relevance to the
1940s wasn't it wasn't obvious to the
most generous I it in fact it was it was
my editor Shelley Shelley Wang Ranger
who by subtitling it gave it a kind of
order by noting that you know there was
book Bohemia there were the arts there
were politics and these were basically
the spheres you know that you know which
was enough to encompass and I shall now
confide the terrifying fact that the
manuscript was once about twice as long
as it is that as it stands now I would
say actually what happened was that was
a group that I you know was the group's
life but being fascinated with were the
early Bohemians in Greenwich Village the
generation of bats that max Eastman and
his sister crystal Floyd Dell a lot of
people whose names are largely lost to
fame there were the nude art New York
Dada is like Baroness Elsa LeBlanc
luring often and I both felt I was both
fascinated by them I went to the library
and had that experience I'm sure you've
had many
when you like you're the first person to
check out a book in you know in 40 years
and you wonder if this shows your being
scholarly or you're just too far off the
beaten track but it but the thing is
they were both fascinating and
frustrating in equal measure because you
can't be sure you're getting them right
you know I mean with one's
contemporaries you have reasonable sets
of the background but these but at a
certain point you're reaching your hand
too far over the table and so you wonder
but you know there's a there's a
terrifying line that I think Christopher
Isherwood once said gore Vidal who of
course wrote historical novels and an
issue would said how terrifying that
must be imagine you've just written and
the birds began to sing and then you
wonder were there birds in the 4th so
that's why I think it's this thing the
early Greenwich Village bohemian sites
they were the answer to both questions
really
oh well that's particularly interesting
but talking about them sue one of the
things that struck me in the book was
that although it was allegedly this a
post-war period you moved back and forth
it didn't start in with them although it
does in some ways they are early on but
but at on page 350 there might be some
return to a much earlier age and I I
sort of wondered it and made me remember
something Melville had written I think
it was in the confidence man in his last
book when he was really angry at the
reading reading public and he it went
like this
describing the narrative that the reader
is going to receive it says the
narrative goes forward and goes backward
as occasion calls nimble center
circumference elastic you must have so
you have good good good predecessor
particularly in this particular thing
but I don't know I suppose on one of
those historians you know just goes down
illogical lime and and maybe misses some
things by not breaking that and so it
seems to me that you had a purpose in
the times when you did back up or
sometimes scoot forward well you put me
and you put me in exalted company for a
change well I am grateful but there's
certainly the in the presence of an
exalted phrase but no iiiii this just
aggressiveness and desultory a tional
desultory nasai I have I have noticed I
did has even been pointed out that there
is a parallel to my conversation but I
do think I'd use one particular example
though I mean obviously nothing's
nothing starts there's no new moment no
original moment in history I wrote a lot
about the the sort of homosexual
underworld of the of the 1940s part
much of which wasn't an underworld you
suddenly had you know during the war the
homosexuality came into an unprecedented
public visibility and became a literary
theme so I certainly know who believed
with Truman Capote I mean no one is I
write the book is going to is going to
mistake the symbolic swampland of other
voices other rooms for a literal
transcription of reality but you kind of
get where he's coming from
and then with the doll he was sort of
suspected of doing an artless
documentary but then again there had
been gay had always been a game to New
York and of course you know and Engrish
or chop sees done is the classic study
of the obits 19th century reading so one
finds oneself
you know headed back you're inevitably
drawn back to the past it's just to
explain what people are doing they're
doing in the future and I think
particular particularly the other
elements of New York sociology I find
that happening to me okay so that so in
other words that there are stories that
really require a restart yeah it's not
fitting right we're doing when I'm when
I wrote New York intellect I had a
little epilogue we
maybe was a mistake because I did too
much into stiffly small of a space but
one of the things I argued in here was
that the culture of the post-war period
there the forties onward to say the 60s
was the culture of the eye and the ear
that I diminished the written word you
on page 52 say that is supremely the
city of the word I do we find ourselves
that disagree well there's a simple
answer but I think even though and
you've shown some of your incidence on
images already but yours is very heavily
on the literature no I think it's a it
is a funny thing where you know where
the cultural balance like I mean in the
course of writing this book I sort of
became a born-again McLuhan I I became
convicted I'll you know of course I mean
we all know the out it isn't necessary
to include his ideas or it but in the
air versus the 60s but fundamentally he
maintained that in any given culture any
given time there was a dominant medium
in opposing it might be but it might be
the year might be the eye that might be
heavy it might be light you know I mean
that's you know Egyptians you know was
heavy you know paper you know with
cuneiform and play tablets of Babylonia
was we know is very heavy then you get
more more ethereal and the 20th century
in 21st century is like a progressive
ethereal ization you know some of us
here of course can remember how heavy
culture was literally right for the 60s
one of the terrors of moving your
friends helping your friends move was
not so it's not only the books which
were bad enough but the phonograph
records which way I mean one you know
well not this is all God you know I read
everything he's just got the tablet said
you've got hit and in the
iPhones and you've got his literal
ethereal ization radio with more
ethereal in the movies the movies were
bulky they came in reels and this is all
changed now the balance of I nearby
called New York supremely a city of
words I think that this was and the last
epoch in which people really organize
their daily lives around routines of
literacy if you're going to waste time
you wouldn't be to cheat novel people
read newspapers around the clock there
are about 15 16 17 dailies in New York
many of many of them like life the
foreword would lose an idiot foreign
language and and just think New York is
an alphabetical City in the simple in
the simplest way organized that an
alphabetical grid and I think that the
eye and ear people the concept which
I've put it which I first encountered in
your book and then it's found in court
virginal tops writes about yes we're you
know the number of people who
appreciated Abstract Expressionists art
it's early days or or even Picasso and
Matisse and so on we're a relatively
elite group and I think the I hear
people were did not represent the you
know the the connection with the
literary culture that the partisan
review crowd had who were men of the
books intended with the exception of
Clement Greenberg not much of an
interest or expertise in painting
sculpture
well that's true there was a wonderful
article that Irving how wrote in this I
guess the late 60s when he what did he
call when a literary person stumbles
into the New York City Ballet and he
became a fan of this and even the it is
true that the with the exception of
Greenberg the partisan review people
were pretty an attentive to music or or
especially the visual one of the things
I liked about your book is the relative
marginalization of the partisan media
there are so many books
that partisan review there's at least a
dozen recent not counting the
autobiographies it was a small group of
people with a small circulation and as
you point out who were positioned
essentially politically in the early
Cold War to come up with a kind of
position that was viable or seemed to be
viable it was why the CIA funded them
but I think that that is a there's a
good point but I I I guess I'm willing
to talk about the elite and where they
were going and it does seem to me that
it was painting it was music Virgil
Thompson being a key figure Bernstein
who you mentioned in many others that
that that is where the American or the
New York we're cutting edge
internationally in a way that I'm not
sure that you could say the same for the
the the writers I'm not some yes I mean
bellows about to merge to be a figure of
international but not so much yeah no I
agree I think like you know in the inner
intellect you you know you refer to you
know the the role of partisan review
that was there's a cultural import
device you know II did a lot a lot it
right up through say Susan Sontag who
was first started out and in partisan at
least gained her first renowned for
awful you know for her article on camp
in partisan review if she was telling
the news from Europe it was a very old
is a very old-fashioned role here here
are the new French movies you know here
are the new Italian semiotician get with
it people know and this you know I mean
there was a you know celebrated book
about New Yorker the twenties called
Port of New York about the importation
of European ideas and artifacts and I
think and I think but I think one thing
that happened of course is is the eye
and the
the AI people so far one I think I you
know I think beginning with the 1960s
music art became much more important to
our daily experience to more people than
it had been before and that was where
the news was coming from but not the the
novel was no longer bringing the news in
the way that paintings and happenings
were bringing in the news okay I'm happy
with that I wanted to switch to the
question of empire in person the
subtitle and I guess I didn't see enough
Empire to put it on the but maybe
there's a case for it that I missed well
know that you know in the thousand pages
that did not work there's more about
about Empire and you know as I think I
may have spared my editor this terrible
news that but as soon as the book was
officially finished which was which was
decided in New York and not in my study
I immediately launched on writing three
essays in which I was going to make my
case for various various aspects of the
book about historical perspective and in
modernism and and the Empire but I think
you're right I like having it in there
because people might you know you know
like it might stir interest it's
certainly time timely anything I in it
and it wound up in a way being relegated
to a footnote I blad it's in there
because it might lead people to read
that no because you didn't have the
benefit of the endnotes I guess I have
their notes but it didn't they weren't
numbered
empire those of you who know those of
you who have long memories and were
reading the New York Times back Terry
the days of the George of the George W
Bush presidency and the beginnings of
our misadventures in Iran or that was an
unknown end in Iraq I should say there
was an unnamed administration grey
eminence who turned out to be Karl Rove
who said you know you people belong to
the reality convention you don't
understand we are an empire now we
create the reality and you report on it
now this was a moment of breathtaking
hubris that you would think every
classes the land would have risen up to
say you don't know whether where you're
going hear that then again my friends on
the Left the people apart is you know
not partisan revealed it's a
counterpunch Jacobin and all these
people use empire usually with a capital
e to refer to an endlessly malefic
political force which is sort of forever
you know pulled the rug out from under
the people even though the people are
resilient and great in them they will
prevail in the end and i did you know
the particularly usage here is one that
i owe to a late friend political
scientist Ron Sherman in which he just
says that world that America during
World War two under Franklin Roosevelt
became an unprecedented kind of empire
we weren't interested in territory it
wasn't some silly escapade like the
spanish-american war which got us a few
scraps in the Caribbean and and the
Philippines I never fit into the
American order very comfortably it was
about having you know basis of what
amounted to fortresses you know in the
hundreds all over the earth it was about
having a world in which there was no
election which was not of interest to
America now of course this may all end
if Donald Trump becomes president
because he seems to think autarky is the
wave of the future but it was that sense
that I'm using Empire okay there was
though I mean one could have said there
was a
a moment of a different kind of empire
between it as you I think suggested when
you were talking earlier and that is
between 45 and 50 without any military
action the United States at that point
was more dominant than ever before and
ever will be again you're devastated
Asia devastated and it does seem to me
that I'm less comfortable with the bases
all over the place because it wasn't
just pieces there there were troops
weather again and again and again but
anyway enough of that I want to get back
to the internal ok yeah you you showed
the some of the wonderful Bernice
Bernice Abbott photographs which
incidentally the negatives for those
incredible photographs are in the
possession of this archives here and I'd
like you to talk about whether the New
York of 45 or 42 45 which is at least
the initial core whether it has more in
common with the world 40 years or 50
years before those photographs by her or
the 50 years or so after those that's
faster yes it is it it is true in the
photographs of Abbott are you know [ __ ]
to be the most fascinating of what I
call book but you know this sort of
civic photographers maybe this maybe
maybe this is influence on the civic
intellectuals but it's a funny
combination I mean this was a
paradigmatic New Yorker beginning with
the fact that she of course was from the
Midwest it was here in time for the
beginning of the Revels of the Jazz Age
moved to Paris you know apprenticed with
man-ray another New Yorker of course in
Paris it was a great portrait
photographer if you own any copies of
James Joyce and paperback and I suspect
you all do
those are Berenice Abbott's photographs
of James Joyce
came back to photograph changing New
York and her whole idea was to was to
witness the ever metamorphosizing
metamorphose ISM I will certainly get
some variation of metamorphosis out here
we've got an endlessly changing city and
the and the classic Berenice Abbott
image is of you know an enormous
monolith somewhere some great citadel of
finance but then there's a frayed
clothing line in front of that and then
there's a menu with a thousand different
specialties on a blackboard and like
boiled octopus is always among them so
it's a city that fits you know Frederick
Jameson's classic definition of the
Derna T which which is this confusion of
realms you know the sort of the
streamlined you know and the primitive I
mean many European visited many of the
Europeans who came in the 30s fleeing
Hitler's Europe we're really constantly
struck by what they seemed to them to be
the primordial quality it was just a
scary place it was like a lot of ogres
castles you know so I think that I think
that a curious way that is the sort of
you know I think that she bullet that
that belong to a particular moment which
I did think we lost and this is sort of
suburbanization
of New York and the fifties and sixties
well you gave me a lot of her but what
about 50 years but what would the
cultural did the cultural history you're
telling does it bear a relation I guess
I'll say if thinking 50 years back or so
I'm talking about maybe the the the
World War one pre-world War one New York
which was New York in a special moment
or yes where we are not so much now but
maybe in the later 20th century Oh what
is the relation of those are they
similar are there connections are there
is it go like this does it go like this
yes I mean it's funny I happen to know
but the historical span of this book is
it's wonderful to have the Library of
Congress
Hellion because what it states is New
York New York history 1898 1951 New York
New York civilization New York New York
intellectual life 20th century Greenwich
Village New York New York
it'll actual like 20th century but I see
but I went back to 1898 and yeah I think
that in a way and the nineteen fifty
ended a span that did begin you know in
the last you know during you know in
around 1890 it was a spanish-american
war Theodore Roosevelt became became
president after McKinley's assassination
there was a great civic culture out of
which the Roosevelt submerged both both
of them emerging
Theodore Roosevelt obviously is a
Republican progressive and then Franklin
Roosevelt who began as a cabinet member
or sub cabinet member under Woodrow
Wilson and and then rose to the heights
and I think it could be just called the
longer age of Roosevelt if you wanted to
embrace a great man theory of the period
and I think that you know you sort you
know as Ike was I mentioned two to a
dear friend recently I was I was
wandering about town and I just said you
know I always had this ambition of sort
of being photographed around all the
major monuments to FDR I realized that
this would take a very long time one
last I think short because we're just
about done what was the condition of the
writer in nineteen forty 1940s as
opposed to the writer today in Alford
caissons first autobiography he talks
about supporting himself while he's
writing his classic on native ground he
says you know I could get a pick up a
review at the New Republic another one
and some other magazine and a couple of
the newspaper and you're always able to
do my work it's clearly can't be done
today
what are the consequences of this that
is it traffic cases of course a classic
example of that as was as was Malcolm
Cowley who collected some later pieces
out of the title and I worked at the
writers trade there was this kind of
literary cult I mean white writers in a
way we're at the set of literary culture
in the most literal way and that the
movies bought novels the successful
novel could make one of paper
millionaire and this didn't happen to a
few people you could always sell out to
Time Inc the Irving Irving how whom you
knew whom he mentioned was we would
invented the term New York intellectuals
in later years was offered a job doing
book reviews at Time magazine he thought
of course oh this is selling out to use
the idiom of the 60s so they went to
Philip Roth who's known as the chief of
partisans for advice and Philip Roth
said better to work for one boss one bad
boss than a dozen what I think is
happening today is that it was possible
to cobble together that kind of way of
life as a man of letters to you know in
to use that an old-fashioned expression
which was a Pitta Mies by Edmund Wilson
today I think it's quite different
because the writers life has been
institutionalized there was this essay
in n + 1 which has succeeded partisan
review as the most fearsome intellectual
fearsome and self-assured intellectual
in general to come out of New York as
they published called MFA versus NYC the
idea that the professional MFA Canada
who attends class is taught by people
write novels that no not many people
read but who watch our published and
then you are taught to write such books
yourself is is very different from NYC
which to them represents life you know
and I think there's something something
to that you know alright I think that
now it's the audience's opportunity
if a question a professor mentor you
could call or on the on the person and
ask you to ask your question into the
microphone if there are any questions
you know that the future always seems to
be so much different than it turns out
and I'm a little bit curious about the
time around 1930 where there was a an
author historian James Ford who talked
about slums in New York City as being a
crisis so significant that he correct he
hypothesized it would take 132 years to
eradicate them and what that opens up in
the context of what you're talking about
is how how do do you see the impact of
the future changing in a way that out
paces is prognosis and and what's the
impact and that both a literary side and
a cultural side as we move into the Cold
War and and beyond you know that's a
terrific question and I had that period
fascinates me as I said the period about
you know between the the helplessness of
the Hoover administration and the the
enormous energy and briault of the
Roosevelt administration a lot of the
interesting thing that was in the twice
or even three times in the first half of
the 20th century people imagined they
were moving into a period of sort of
permanent administration leaving aside
the First World War which which also led
to a utopian moment afterwards briefed
fairly briefly but during the Depression
it seemed a lot of people this was just
going to go on you know there's a famous
story in those days of course luminaries
were interviewed on a dockside when they
arrived on the Aquitania and john john
maynard keynes the great economist
disembarked and the reporter said has
there ever been anything like these
conditions and he said yes it was called
the Dark Ages
it lasted 800 years you know and then
again in 19 1945 of course you know New
York blazed compared to the darkness of
you know the spread all across Eurasia
the poet Stephen spender you know saw
the ruins of Berlin and you know the
Chancellery
collapse of the charred ruins here
therefore everywhere from you know
Palermo to Leningrad and he said they
seem to be emblems of a disaster that
people will come and gape at for
centuries to come
well by the end of the century the
Bulgarian artist Christo had wrapped
yeah yes the future usually outs out
scripts are we're always out scripts are
prophetic power but I do think it's
important that there was this enormous
imagination of disaster and
understandably so after the after the
two wars had the depression yes thank
you
that was wonderful by the way I really
enjoyed question do you have anything
about the Harlem Renaissance in your
book I have some it's one of the it's
it's something that so many brilliant
books this isn't easy so many brilliant
books have been written about the Harlem
Renaissance right you know I I do talk
there's a line that I wish that I had
that I had that I wish I put in however
from John Hope Franklin I was a great
historian when he's what he said there
are people he has a chapter his classes
his classic history which he says people
talk about the Harlem Renaissance what
they should talk about is the continuing
Harlem Renaissance his answer was yes
there were many cultural glories in the
30s but there were many cultural glories
in the 40s and the 50s been even put
some of the same people now in some
place the late 40s were very hard on
some of the veterans of they've got the
Harlem Renaissance or a Neale Hurston
and it was involved in ridiculous
accusations of she fled to Florida
basically and that did not come back to
New York
certainly James Baldwin could not have
participated becoming James Baldwin when
he was but he was a busboy in the
village but but as I say I in retrospect
I would like to put in more but that was
one of those chapters what I suddenly
thought oh god if I don't get out of the
1920s yeah I'm never going to get to
1950 but there but there there there is
you know some mention particularly you
know as involves
met you know of the masses which was the
basses that it you know added success or
the new mass
it's in the index anybody else comments
surely some comments surely some of some
wild disagreements fascinating talk by
the way
now you mentioned Henry Wallace in the
Progressive Party and there seemed to be
a coterie following him his campaign
posters were done by been shown who was
both a photographer during the for the
WPA and also the art work that he did
and possibly wrote the letter over Diego
Rivera's signature telling Nelson
Rockefeller to go take a hike and I was
just curious about and there were others
in that crowd they in the book and I
just bought it so I haven't had a chance
to check the index but you are there
they seem to be others and also the
group theater I seem to see this whole
left-wing coterie labouring of American
culture in which he argues I think he
might well it's a you know it's one of
those things you know if you arranged
the figures in the landscape one way you
could hear you're going to get a very
different picture then with them with it
you know when you've read more
foreshadowing or loops in the back of
the backer I think that the late 40s was
the last emperor essence of popular
front culture and that was the and its
last hurrah was the Wallace campaign and
these were the people who get out of
many members of the Communist Party but
other others who were anti-communist but
who we have enlisted under FDR's banner
and Ben Shawn was serving one of the
most important artists Leonard
Bernstein's support supported Wallace
for president but Norman Mailer's
support that Henry Wallace
the president my father supported him he
was and it was and you find this being
carried over into the culture of the
fifties it becomes increasingly
disaffected it's grivet it's driven
virtually underground I mean Henry
Wallace was was you know this exam but
not on camera but in camera by the house
on American Activities Committee I mean
the other the spectacle of a former vice
president being a you know in
practically in the duck but I'm curious
trauma do you think if you were adding
to your appendix and newly our intellect
how would you answer that question
[Music]
can't remember entirely what I had yeah
I think you can have the question that
was a long time ago that book no but I
was about partisan plays an interesting
role as you say and you said earlier
because partisan joy MacDonell hate it
and Dwight MacDonald was that an
enormous influence at that time because
he for one thing simply a brilliant
writer and some and and variable in his
political positions but he hated Henry
Wallace or he was sort of obsessed with
Henry Wallace he didn't hate him but he
and he said he referred to a debased
provincial dialect which he called
Wally's you know and compared and
compared to a wintry snow storm that
covered everything but partisan sort of
Lea there was one tradition that sort of
stood against the Popular Front culture
and it's you know and it and this and
you could still hear the the some of the
rumbles of this in the sixties I don't
know if anybody here remembers was once
a famous few between Mary McCarthy and
Lillian Hellman and they were on the
Dick Cavett show which of course was
like the great Agora of the night jeans
and you know and you know basically you
know uh Cavett was egging on Mary
McCarthy and finally she said she said
everything she writes is a lie including
thaw and up and so of course Lillian
Hellman sued and this went on for quite
time but this was actually a battle of
it back back to those days I mean you
know she would accuse Lillian Hellman
would accuse her writing like John
Steinbeck or vice versa so these the
battles about the Popular Front which
involved views on the Spanish Civil War
of which the last American veteran just
died views about the views about the New
Deal views about the Communist Party
views about Abstract Expressionism these
are all these were all mixed up with
left-wing politics in the 40s and those
quarrels are still going on yes the
brazen age right there period so what
would you call it twenty besides the
Jazz Age I don't know yep but no that's
interesting quite I think that well it's
a funny thing I mean a lot of people in
the 30s thought that the you know
thought of it as being spree you know we
I do to mention in passing that allot it
to us it's obvious that the 1920s was a
Golden Age of culture it was quite
simple I mean the you know it was the
great age of the American novice age of
the American Novel since the 19th
century it was the high age of American
modernism these are books that stiva
that are still read by read by millions
maybe it was equally inventive in arts
and so yeah it was a gold date but a lot
of people at the beginning of the 30s
thought oh no no we went we went astray
and partially this is because the the
intellectuals became you know became
completely disenchanted with the
dominant business culture there's a
great chapter in an Arthur Schlesinger
book the crisis of the old order called
the disenchantment of the intellectuals
that he quotes miss gerald as you know
as saying it was characteristic of the
Jazz Age that it cared nothing at all
for politics and then by 1933 it seemed
that you couldn't do that
and Fitzgerald began reading Karl Marx
doubtless to his edification so no so I
would say it was a golden and for us
it's obviously a golden age for culture
yeah but I do think some of these some
of the same people who were very you
know even though anyway also went
through a very political
so I think that it did seem in
retrospect that this disenchantment was
kind of expensive oh now this depends on
the presidential election this could
turn into a Latin Age very quickly do
you have any you know are there any
figures that occur to you any bet should
like to me
hey my editors here
well I do think that if that Trump right
now is you know represents a repudiation
of a lot of the orthodoxies of the
post-war of the post-war era obviously
to say that well you know I mean did you
say that well maybe we should sort of
cut back on NATO is to go against a
consensus that goes right back to the
Truman administration you know at that
time there was a the Dow largely
forgotten Arthur Vandenberg Republican
senator who joined with Truman and in
creating that consensus Trump represents
I you know I think a kind of kind of or
at least a seized on a populist moment
that has a lot to do with Adi
establishment this is all this is I'm
sure it's all painfully obvious but I do
think in Presidium if you could be if
you ask how does this relate to 1950 I
would say that basically we had a
consensus right through the 60s there
was there were things was just taken for
common you know I'm both you know on
both sides of the barricades and I don't
think that we can say that right now I
think we really are at a watershed
comparable to say 1912
only the cast of characters in 1912 it
was all three candidates with
progressives right we have this case but
the 1912 it did represent a
consolidation of our progressive yes in
this case in this case it says the I
perhaps watershed is this good intact
but it might be as consequential I fear
so I want to thank everyone for coming
and thank David Reed and Thomas
commander
always wonderful conversation and we can
certainly continue the conversation but
there's wine so we should enjoy a glass
of wine and the books that are on sale
Oh
which will be signed by these two
amazing offers